this program is brought to you by emory
university is unlikely that in one move
we are going to get a total
transformation but what it means is that
we have to do the most we can with the
current dynamic and understanding that
we have to have another cycle at this
another effort to help libya come to
terms with how to build a democratic
constitutional governance structure of
course people are not prepared I'm not
organized are not the fifth effective in
their resistance that is to be expected
because they didn't have the experience
to do it but empowering them supporting
them helping them and to understand that
it may take longer than it is not like a
quick fix every time I mean Gaddafi may
appear to be winning in the short term
but his arms supplies his financial
support of resources are diminishing and
he is dependent on the international
community for that I would emphasize the
global nature of the response the more
international they better if it is
perceived to be American or Western
that's going to be counterproductive so
although in reality Western powers the
United States and European powers are
likely to play the leading role but it
should be done institutionally through
the United Nations through the African
Union through the Arab League so that it
is not perceived as a new phase of
colonialism I think the point is not to
give up on democratic change but to
understand the dynamic of the verb
democratic change is going to be
different for each society given its own
history and its own context and for me
even going through the stages of having
to go through and a not very successful
transition or a partial transition is
part of the process the preceding
program is copyrighted by emory
university